momentos de intensa emoción se vivieron
en la mañana de este jueves en italia en
ocasión de la primera jornada por la
memoria de las víctimas de coronavirus
en el país el jefe del gobierno italiano
mario draghi participó a una ceremonia
en bérgamo en el norte del país una de
las ciudades más fuertemente golpeadas
por la pandemia en italia en el
cementerio de bérgamo mario draghi
depositó una corona de flores antes de
dirigirse al principal parque de la
ciudad en donde fueron plantados 100
árboles en homenaje a las víctimas de la
pandemia durante su intervención mario
draghi recordó los momentos dramáticos
que vivió italia hace un año el 18 de
marzo de 2020 salían de bérgamo filas de
camiones del ejército cargados con
ataúdes ya que los cementerios las
morgues los hornos crematorios de
bérgamo estaban totalmente saturados
italia fue el primer país europeo
golpeado por el coronavirus y hoy el
balance es de más de 103 mil personas
víctimas del coronavirus aquí en italia